À vous de nous dire s'il nous faut
plus ou moins d'Europe,
en tout cas, certainement
moins d'Europe
que celles que nous connaissons sous la
gouvernance et la coolition.
Je le rappelle quand-même,
autour de cette table,
euh, à la fois des macronistes, à la fois du groupe ppe,
de monsieur François Xavier, euh. Bellamy,
mais aussi des socialistes,
et ponctuellement, d'ailleurs, alliés aux écologistes.
C'est cette collision, aujourd'hui,
euh, qui est la majorité de Ursula vendeur leyenne, euh.
Et qui a mené
toutes les politiques que nous souhaitons, euh, combattre,
et plus d'Europe, euh, d'une autre Europe,
d'une vision différente,
qui pour moi, serait non plus cette Europe
gouvernée par le centre et la gauche, mais 1 Europe
authentiquement de droite,
qui défendrait son identité et sa civilisation, euh, face,
euh. Au contraire, à cette Europe qui accélère, euh,
l'islamisation,
euh, qui défendrait ses frontières,
face à 1 Europe qui, au contraire, l'ouvre,
1×1 Europe
également qui défendrait sa souveraineté alimentaire,
son autonomie, euh,
euh, euh, son autonomie, pardon, énergétique,
euh plutôt que cette Europe du fanatisme écologique,
euh. Et de la et de la décroissance,
euh, 1 Europe qui protégerait nos entreprises,
euh, qui, euh, comment dire, encouragerait la recherche,
euh. Plutôt que 1 grande Europe qui nous ouvre,
finalement, qui ouvre le marché aux 80,
euh. Et qui nous, euh,
nous assomme de normes, de charges, de birocracie,
et je crois, j'en finirai par là,
qu'il y a 1 opportunité historique,
parce que, pour la 1ère fois.
Nous pourrons sortir vanderlion
et sortir cette majorité
et ainsi
imposer cette robe de droite à laquelle j'aspire.